Vladimir Putin suffers Cardiac Arrest
sparking massive alarm in Kremlin inner
circle and a shout out to Timothy
Whitaker in the Super Chat who asked I
had not seen this story it's from 16
hours ago totally missed this one but uh
I did just check it real quick and there
are a ton of outlets that are covering
this saying Vladimir Putin is alleged to
have suffered a cardiac arrest arrest in
his private Moscow apartment on Sunday
evening a telegram Channel believed to
be run by a former Kremlin Insider
reported that incident saying the
Russian leader was found by guards on
the floor of the bedroom lying on the
floor rolling his eyes oh doctors
reportedly called in immediately and
they later diagnosed a 71-year-old
having suffered a cardiac arrest it's
different from a heart attack Cardiac
Arrest is when you heart stops something
like this was reported about Putin a
couple months ago wasn't it he's been
having a lot of medical issues that's
horrible to hear well I mean the scary
thing is what happens to Russia without
Putin yeah it's a big vacuum yeah yep he
not a good dude well you know what they
might just start fighting among
themselves and then lose all uh lose all
interest in Ukraine and then we could
just be like okay see you see you this
might prevent World War II that would be
helpful kind of a horrifying thing to
think like if this man dies World War II
is averted well yeah then Russian Civil
War 3 or they do that a lot yeah the
thing is whoever takes over for Russia
and we we would think they might fun
amongst themselves but we don't actually
know if there's not a clear uh successor
to his throne could be even
worse they have pren out of the way
remember the uh so he's out of the way
and so a bunch of like cuz he would be
much tougher on Ukraine than uh the next
guy might be to you right I agree but
didn't they get rid of most of those
guys in that how do you know I don't
know anything I don't know anything
which is why we didn't cover this story
at post-millennial I just couldn't tell
yeah it's hard uh and also when you see
stuff like this it's hard for me not to
be like when is the Kremlin statement
saying like somebody slipped in Poison
is com but yeah I was interested in this
story too and I couldn't track down like
I find it very difficult to cover
overseas stuff because I really I really
only know just the one language well
especially with China and Russia I think
if if anything I was actually was
concerned about this as well if there's
power vacuum this is before I even knew
that he had this heart attack I talked
with a friend of mine if there is a
power vacuum in Russia what's to say
that China isn't going to go you know
knocking on Russia's door I don't know
I'm I'm just you know it's just a whole
other thing I'm throwing out there but
there's definitely animosity between
totally random crazy thought that you
probably start thinking about when you
get older it's like you could be taking
a shower in the morning and like let's
say your wife or your husband or
whatever is like all right I'm going to
go you know walk the dog or whatever and
then you slip and hit your head
and you're dead that's why you should
get married because they'll come back
after they walk the dog and be like the
shower is still running and they'll
check on you and that's and that's the
thing unless they hate you there a lot
there a lot of stories about like ELD
people who will just go missing and then
a week later people are just like let's
go check up they've been missing for a
week and they're like oh they slipped in
the bathroom and died yeah yeah like you
could just like Putin so the report is
like his guards heard a thump and then
ran up and found him I don't know if
they actually had heart attack right
they're saying unconfirmed reports but a
bunch of viot are carrying this this
this this rumor
and just imagine like for the average
person who has a heart attack there is
no guard waiting downstairs to hear the
thumb that's why they invented the
button thing although if you have a
heart attack your unconscious you can't
press Your Life Alert button although
there's I think one that like if you
fall hard enough it'll totally there's
like necklaces and stuff too oh the
iPhone does that yeah there was a there
was a what is it like if you get into a
car accident it instantly calls 911 or
whatever yeah yeah you got into
technology so crazy well like there's
one story where a dude dropped the phone
and the phone thought was a car accident
so it called the police and they found
it or something oh wow like fell off his
bike or something like that I remember
it was just a couple years ago my mom
said honey I I'm suddenly afraid of
falling down that must be a crazy she's
like she's in her mid 70s she's
extremely active she just got back from
a month traveling around Italy right
Italy and Ireland and just living her
best she was yeah she just does whatever
she wants but she's still a little bit
afraid of falling
down yeah yeah I just kind of hope that
when I'm old I'm like fat and so when I
fall down it doesn't Cushing nothing
gets broken that is the argument for
obesity right now although your bones
get brittle you can't walk around you
get the veins you have a heart issue
that seems bad to the diabetes you know
no the good news is if you're fat you
won't get old oh if you're fat you won't
get old so that's a win W that's Young
Forever Tak you fat Die Young stop
working out all together wow I'm also
equally concerned that Putin having a
heart attack could lead to World War II
yeah that's what what's the alternate
scenario what do you think that without
Putin stabilizing the region it results
in power struggles and then it leads to
conflict outside of outside of Russia
which drags other people in Putin may be
a stabilizing Force stopping certain
elements of of the Russian military from
engaging in certain actions right yeah
like look at Gaddafi after after he went
to Libya collapsed yeah but I mean worse
than that let's say like put's heart
attack and dies then a military leader
says I'm the next in command so I'm
going to do this thing fighting erupts
inside Russia but then this guy says
send in new you know Kev or whatever
something crazy yeah yeah Putin's been a
tough Force for for Russia for a long
time and I years I don't think that this
war is just simple land dispute I think
it's definitely a proxy war to test the
endurance of Russia um you know kind of
caused by American influence but yeah I
don't want I I would rather Putin not
die think he's he's protected a lot of
the Christian Community in in Russia and
you've seen zalinski shut down Orthodox
churches in Ukraine and I'm not saying
they were Russian Orthodox right the
Russian Orthodox Churches yeah
interesting yeah and so I don't know I I
do think it would bring in uh World War
III if he died yeah I mean I mean the
question at this point is there are so
many different scenarios to get us into
World War III are there any scenarios to
keep us out to keep it from happening
put America first stay away from
everyone else but multiple arguments
have been made for why that would result
in World War the first two other world
wars started when America stayed out
so beno's argument is that if Iran or
other countries stage a ground invasion
of of Israel or begin air strikes Israel
will respond with nuclear weapons which
will create regional conflict which
bleeds out into hemisphere inter
whatever interational yeah and then the
US has no choice but to get involved
well Mark Levan was on Fox News the
other day and he was just going like
eviscerating the host saying well Israel
is surrounded and they may have to
resort to uh you know nuclear weapons
just infuriated and I I don't think
it'll come to that point I don't think
it'll come to that point unless Israel
provokes it I just don't see that
happening but what I will say is even if
it does you know bleed out into the
International Community I still think
America should stay out of it I think
we're a strong enough entity to keep to
ourselves what about NATO do you don't
think we should I think we
you don't think we should defend our
allies I think we should pull out a NATO
so we should be have no friends at all
in the world I think our friends should
be ourselves and we should put America
first because we haven't done that in we
be like that we're going to be like that
girl in New York who marries
herself
stages she's so happy oh my God she is
so happy she has no children she has no
man she has a very nice dress and happy
girl probably locks her apartment door
which is the thing I think America
should do I think completely talk about
the border and when she falls down in
the shower there is nobody there to help
her I mean we have a bunch of stat that
are the size of European countries I I
can't say what our our interventionist
strategy should be I generally feel like
before we delve in further to any
International Skirmish we should have a
stronger border policy uh and then we
can talk about it it's hard to have
these conversations knowing that we are
like yeah yeah yeah you're bad and we
want to support you and also come across
our border anytime no questions asked
also maybe from Canada if you fly there
and hop like this is not good we need a
strong National Defense Trump says it
this is coming straight from Trump's
mouth we have to put America first
that's not a controversial thing to say
we've got so many problems that are
crippling us and leaving us basically
paralyzed in the water and our kids are
killing themselves because they have no
purpose they're gender dysphoric and
we're focusing on a bunch of regional
skirmishes thousands of miles halfway
around the world let's focus on putting
America First why is
I agree but being being isolationism
being isolationist and saying we're
going to totally isolate ourselves is
also kind of a death now because we
don't have enough manufacturing to keep
this country going we have so many
things that are also need to built up
our resources not are not in the same
level as other countries we have we have
natural gas and we have oil we should be
drilling I problem with that I'm sure
you agree with that as well but I still
think that like okay if you want to do
that we'll give ourselves like a 20-year
timeline because we can't just do that
tomorrow or we're screwed yeah well I
think like you said uh we should be an
autonomous country but maybe should
build the time machine and go back and
put the factories back in America I mean
there's a lot of stuff we should have
done we've been been on a bad path for a
long time I don't think that we should
give up and say like well we've already
been engaged we don't have these things
like but I acknowledge I think you're
totally right we aren't necessarily in
the position to say well we're just
going to do absolutely nothing I do
think before everything else we need to
think about especially if it's an
international war and we know that the
Biden Administration is leaked the thing
is Americans are not used to conflict
being fought on americ soil so I think
it's really important that we secure the
border right it was like it's been 7
million people since the Biden
Administration took office and in Trump
in 2020 it was less than half a million
yes and the majority of them are
fighting it was 480,000 four no 4 yeah
480,000 in 2020 I'm pretty sure and it's
been 7 million since 2021 so good I'm
glad that we're entering International
skirmishes this is a great idea well
they're trying to displace the nation's
image bearers and I think that's you've
seen that just the way that they
demonize white people white Christians
especially white Christian men moreover
especially they're trying to do that and
they're like you said they're sing 7
million people in that's a huge fraction
of our population and I don't think we
should stand oddly by we need a and
they're not done they're flying people
in from Venezuela they're like oh these
Venezuelans they should get all of the
things and New Yorkers should get
nothing we'll just send everybody we got
to reinforce our border we got to have a
stronger National Defense otherwise
we're going to be the laughing stock in
the next 10 years I agree but I think 10
years I know right already there pretty
much it's like right now thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net